this morning allegations of a cover-up
at a local elementary school the
allegations come from Clark County
School District police it all surrounds
an incident that was caught on camera
inside of a special education classroom
in October an aide accused a teacher of
tackling a student with autism at
gerheim elementary a police report show
investigators found nothing was wrong
neither did the child's Guardian however
police did find internal School
paperwork on the incident was filled out
incorrectly and aide says she was told
to back date those papers we spoke with
the child's caregiver it was exactly
what we thought we knew it our gut knew
it she scooped them right up and and it
was just exactly what he needed
in a police report the investigating
officer said there appeared to be an
attempted cover-up with failings from
the teaching Aid special ed facilitator
as well as the principal the teacher was
suspended but she's appealed that action
and she did decline an interview request
with us CCSD meantime says it's looking
into the officer's report